what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chain
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off
[Music]
the following episode is part of the
off-the-chain automation series
sponsored by iota the goal of this
special series is to explore the
intersection of distributed ledger
technology and automation specifically
around digital currencies digital
wallets and machine-to-machine
transactions my core belief is that
every stock bond currency and commodity
will eventually be digitized and
distributed ledger technology will
empower the full potential of automation
to be realized
iota is the sponsor of the automation
series their mission is to support the
research and development of new
distributed ledger technologies
including IOT tangle the iota foundation
encourages the education and adoption of
distributed ledger technologies through
the creation of ecosystems and the
standardization of these new protocols
you can find out more about the
automation series and iota in the show
notes
Anthony pomp Liana is a partner at
Morton Creek Digital all opinions
expressed by pomp or his guests on this
podcast are solely their opinions and do
not reflect the opinions of Morgan Creek
digital or Morton Creek Capital
Management you should not treat any
opinion expressed by pomp as a specific
inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
Richard soli is an American computer
scientist and businessman and chairman
and CEO of the object Management Group
Incorporated
he's also executive director of the
cloud standards customer Council an
executive director of the industrial
internet consortium managed by the OMG
in this conversation we discussed the
importance of technology consortiums his
past experience with interconnected
machines and devices where
cryptocurrencies fit in and how
automation is set to transform the IOT
space as a whole I really enjoyed this
conversation and I hope you do as well
alright guys bang bang I've got Richard
here super excited to have this
conversation thank you so much for
taking the time to do this sir it's my
pleasure to be here
or whatever bangbang means hahaha if if
I start every episode with bangbang it
gets everyone focused on what we're
doing so that that's what I've learned
listen you've uh you've been in and
around technology for uh for a few
decades now and and are probably one of
the more experienced people that we've
brought on to the podcast I'm super
excited to have some conversation let's
maybe start with your background and
kind of how you got your career started
and then we can move into some of the
things that you're doing today
sure fine Anthony I have to tell you I
never planned my career such as it is
but it's been an interesting one and I'm
not complaining while getting a
bachelor's master's and PhD in computer
science from a small engineering school
on the river in Massachusetts I I
started there I started or helped to
start five companies three of which did
what startups normally do which is find
a cliff and then jump one of which was
Maude Lee successful because AI
architects was one of the first AI
startups in the 80s and the last of
which was called picture tail the first
successful picture telephone company
which is now part of Polycom so that's
that does that that was real fun but
what was missing was what to do with
these distributed objects that people
were all talking about in the late 80s
so we started a consortium which was a
very popular thing to do in the late 80s
and many construction was started not
many are still around we've been around
for thirty years what we've decided to
do very quickly was set standards and
distributed objects with what we've been
called the corporate standard then we
moved into modeling languages and the
UML languages everyone in computer
science knows is one of our key
standards as well but now OMG develop
standards in 30 different vertical
markets retail systems military systems
command and control satellite control
all sorts of things and if you've got a
mobile phone you've got a corporate
standard you've got an LG standard if
you use the telephone system and the
other way every telecom switch in the
world uses our standards every banking
system every robot
every retail point of sale etc etc so we
went wildly successful as well and in
our thirty years I think it's important
to realize that the purpose of standards
is to make possible interoperability
portability I want to build a solution
and run it on multiple systems and I
want multiple systems to be able to talk
to each other that's all we're asking
for I want to be able to point my device
into the wall as easily as I plug my
device into the wall in most countries
that varies from country to country so
there are multiple standards but there
are only about five or six which is not
too bad makes it possible to plug in my
I raise your just about anywhere so then
in the in the in the early 2000s we were
approached by a group of companies that
wanted to build knowledge and
service-oriented architecture not
standards but they wanted to do
knowledge capture in using service
oriented architecture SOA my initial
reaction was no we don't do that we're a
standards organization my later reaction
was the understanding and realization
that what we did was we managed
ecosystems we help people figure out
what they want to deliver and they they
then to deliver that in an open neutral
international fashion we've been doing
that for for 20 years now and I think
we're quite successful at it most
successfully they Consortium for
information and software quality and a
consortium called the industrial
internet consortium IIC which builds
large industrial IOT solutions all over
the world we've got them in Germany in
France in India in Japan in China in the
United States and so forth just to prove
out how you build industrial IOT systems
not is your refrigerator out of milk but
as your cnc machine in the in a in the
factory down or as your or whatever is
your building in use for example we have
a large smart building outside the
outside of Tokyo and that has been a
tremendous success with - between two
and three hundred companies now building
those systems all over the world they're
about 30 love very large systems 10 to
50 million euro in size and we learned
that a huge amount about how you build
industrial IT systems and publish the
results and I'll Johanna a journal of
innovation I was probably more of a bite
of an answer than you want it no listen
it's fantastic well one of the things
that I'm personally interested in some
assuming other people interested in is
this idea of standards ryi you touched a
little bit on why they're important but
maybe just talk about like what exactly
is a standard and how do you
come through a framework to establish
the standard and then either enforce or
kind of make sure that people are
following that's a really good question
you know a standard would wonder what a
standard is abstractly it's pretty
simple and straightforward I want to be
able to plug logical device into the
wall anywhere in the u.s. I can do that
with a standard two flat blades
electrical connection anywhere in the
u.s. unfortunately not the same in
Europe which uses two round poles and
there are in fact three different
diameters of those two round poles so
there are multiple standards within that
standard but it means a way that the end
user of a solution can connect to the
vendor of a solution and in a way that's
that's not doesn't worry about where
they were who blew built the product you
want that from software as well I want
my air traffic control systems to talk
to each other
I want my ATM to talk to whatever bank I
happened to be you happen to have my
money in regardless of the weather it's
the bank I've got my money in I want my
I want my point-of-sale system to work
together with any printer any any
front-end that I've got regardless of
who built it so vendors of course are
going to try to lock you in quite often
not all I think vendors understand the
value of having choice and they want to
give twice to their end users but the
end users especially want to be able to
have choose based on price quality
support etc and the only way they're
going to get that choice is with
Portability and interoperability that
comes from standardization I wish I
could tell people you've got to use this
entered you must use it but that doesn't
work it never works it's been tried by
governments for thousands of years and
it's never succeeded and certainly not
going to succeed with a private
not-for-profit company called the object
Management Group or the effort that
we've gotten in the IIC to build test
beds but what we've got to do is show
that we've we've come up with a better
solution and the choice allowing choice
that comes from a standard it is making
it possible to build a larger market
it's about having a lot as a piece of a
larger pie rather than a larger piece of
the pie
I think quite often vendors understand
that the three standardization they're
gonna make them buy so much bigger for
their market that they might as well
participate but if it's not going to
then they should try to push us into
into selecting their solution as a
standard nobody we're not controlled by
anyone we are not-for-profit with no
shareholders which makes it possible to
have an open international neutral
process for developing standards and
then convincing people that they are the
best solutions for the problems they
have got it and so as you're going
through that process right you know to
take the electrical outlet or any of the
examples you used that there's obviously
multiple choices for you to choose from
for the standard so how do you come to
the conclusion of which one is the best
is there a group of experts or kind of
industry veterans is there some sort of
problem solving framework like what's
the the process that goes through to
actually selecting the standard there is
in fact a multi-level solution process
that ends up with experts that are
selected by the members not by me but
the reality is the good solution is
going to rise the top by itself
sometimes in about 5% of our cases we've
done this a thousand times in 30 years
sometimes there's more than one solution
that comes about because a vendor
doesn't care as much about having an
open standard and once the solute wants
his or her solution the way it is when
that happens we do something terrible
that is we vote and it may not come up
with the best possible solution but it
comes up with a solution that people can
follow people can trust people can
expect is actually going to be the
standard my great example although we
had nothing to do with it is the VHS
tape it's not nearly as good technically
as the beta tape but it would one and
how did you win you have to ask why did
VHS win over beta if beta is technically
better and the answer is obvious they
went over they went over the the line to
become ubiquitous as soon as it becomes
ubiquitous it's not a standard than
anyone can resist
that's got to be true for the standards
that we develop as well and we spend a
lot of time making sure that it happens
with our multi-step process that that
looks at all the technical experts in
that field and then take
experts about lots of technologies
nevertheless you want that to happen
fast our process takes an average of 17
months
that's not how long it should err an
take that's how long it has taken in the
on average 1000 times we've done it in
30 years the slowest by far was three
years for a UML 2.0 54 companies
participated though so is worth it the
fastest by far was nine months
that was the BPMN standard adopted about
ten years ago but on average at 17
months not so bad for an industry that
was as fast for sure and then one of the
things you mentioned earlier that
specifically around the standards that
again just personally curious about is
this idea of vertical market standards
right so there's protocols let's say for
example the electrical outlet obviously
you could plug all kinds of different
things in there whether it's a washing
machine a coffee you know etc but also
it doesn't have to be just be electrical
appliances it could be everything from
blow dryers charging packs etc so kind
of goes across different industries the
vertical market standard though seems to
be much more focused on very specific
use cases within industries what what's
the difference there is it literally
just that difference of protocols that
versus the industry standard or is there
something else yeah good question it's
not really a difference of protocols the
protocols may remain the same it's
mostly a difference in the vocabulary
let's choose one vertical in which we're
very active
that's Health Care standards in health
care standards we're talking about blood
pressure and we're talking about oh I
don't know I'm not a doctor what I mean
those those that terminology is specific
to health care and it means that that
healthcare healthcare standards which
we've been developing for 15 years are
relevant to healthcare and probably not
to any other any other vertical market
weathered point-of-sale systems or
telecommunication systems and
transportation systems if it is more
relevant outside of healthcare then
we'll take it to our platform Technology
Group which is responsible for
technologies across platforms across
across domains across vertical markets
if it but if it remains in its vertical
market it's relevant to a smaller group
of
companies but it's more relevant than
anything else it's something they have
to follow because they've got to get
interoperability portability in their
vertical market got it um okay
and then this industrial internet
consortium that you're a part of and
leading an effort on explain what
exactly that is so five years ago almost
six years ago now we were approached by
a group of companies that had been
meeting on a monthly basis led by
General Electric said we've got to do
something in industrial IOT consumer and
consumer IOT is what's really captured
the public's imagination a refrigerator
that knows when you're out of milk you
know what I can tell if I'm out of milk
by opening the goddamn refrigerator
that's not the problem and on top of it
that there's no margins left because
we're talking about consumer markets
what goods markets that have no no no
margins but there's an enormous
opportunity in industrial IOT using IOT
and manufacturing smart building smart
cities energy management and precision
agriculture that's where the opportunity
is
but five six years ago we realized there
just was no expertise in that space I I
pointed out to General Electric and a
few others you may have some of the
world's best experts but I've got them
all because I've got two three hundred
companies working together so the point
was to build IOT systems in industrial
settings in manufacturing settings in
smart building settings and harvest best
practices so we'd know who to hire who
trained who to retrain what to retrain
what are the standards required to make
make sure the next time we build this
testbed we can build it more responsibly
and faster that's what we've been doing
further for these years is building we
had now have 30 very large industrial
test beds so I'll give you an example in
in Ireland in the country of Ireland
healthcare information about everyone
who lives in Ireland is kept by the
national government but the ambulance
service is run by the state and run by
what we would call in the US the state
the province what's called in in Ireland
the county so County Cork wanted to
provide better services to their
customers as a smart city solution the
customers are the citizens of that
county of course so now when an
ambulance is on its way to your house if
they know who their
they're gonna download the data for that
person from the national resources in
Dublin and upload it directly into
ambulance so that the paramedics and the
ambulance know exactly how to treat that
customer than might have diabetes or
Alzheimer's or allergies or whatever
furthermore whatever the paramedics do
on the ambulance if they have the time
they're gonna upload the results back
and they'll be shared with the national
resources so every hospital in the
region was gonna have that information
so they can they can better serve the
patient when he or she arising in the
emergency ward
if you've ever ridden in an emergency
ward III apologize I'm sorry you have
but you've seen paramedics screaming of
the doctors and nurses the nurse is
trying to come up with a stabilization
plan than the doctors trying to come up
with a treatment plan that doesn't
happen in County Cork anymore if they
know who they're going to pick up the
ambulance has already beamed the
information back and chosen the correct
Hospital whether it's a an emergency
situation or not a heart attack or
whatever and and the health records of
the person that bring into that hospital
are already in the hospital and updated
with whatever the paramedics have done
in the in in the ambulance it's a small
matter of knowing where the ambulances
are where the homes are where the
problem is where the hospitals are and
making all that data available in
real-time to the hospitals the doctors
and the ambulances it's been a
tremendously successful testbed and
we've learned a lot about how to make
sure that not only are we providing the
useful data to the hospitals but were
you were keeping track of the concerns
or the drivers of the ambulances for
example for sure when you guys go and
you create the system because it sounds
awesome and obviously as it gets
implemented it's pretty obvious to see
with the value and end that can be
created here but how do you go about
getting the implementation or the
adoption done right so you create the
standard you say this is the way things
should be done earlier you said you
can't really force people to do it so
what is that kind of I'll call it a go
to market strategy but it's really just
gaining adoption or implementation from
from the people who could benefit from
it yeah I want to make it clear
we have no way be in a capitalist
society to force anyone to use any
standard that we publish but we getting
adoption is tube is to point out again
that the pie is going to be made great
bigger for the vendors and we're
pointing out to the end-users that their
opportunity is to have choice for price
choice for quality choice for service
whatever therefore is valuable to have a
standard they're gonna want a standard
so let's look at that DLTS for example
distributed ledger technologies there is
no standard for DLTS today we are
developing @omg and we'll deliver next
year standards for interoperability
interoperability between the LTS and
standards for the i/o to tangle that's
something that were that the market
badly needs there's no question they're
gonna adopt it because there's nothing
else to adopt that's where we were quite
happy to be developing a standards in
that sort of market where there is
competition it's a little bit more
difficult and so in those situations
that have competition is there any like
major kind of standards where there's
been one or two that people really two
or three that people can choose from and
you could tell us a story about how
those kind of have played out in the
past huh that's a good question I have
to think about that one though in most
cases our standards are adopted because
they know that our standards are going
to be adopted it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy so I'm not too
worried about it
I can't think of too many cases where
there's where there have been multiple
standards well then the the JavaScript
case the case probably walked away
because the ECMA the European computer
Manufacturers Association had developed
its own JavaScript standard and there
was no need to to create a create one
for ourselves so we did we stopped to
adopting a standard in that space
it would have been competitive with
competitive uselessly and we don't do
standards when somebody else's somebody
else competent is already developing a
standard okay and then so let's talk
about the Internet of Things right as
you guys have started to look they're
part of the mandate or the attention has
turned to DLT sugary ledger technology
maybe just talk a little bit about your
view sitting and having been through a
lot of these different standards in
various verdict
how you guys see DLT internet of things
and some of the internet consortium etc
all all being related you know I I was
super excited when I first heard about D
LTS a few years ago I said this is the
right thing for the IOT space and and
something we can do in the eye I see in
the eye I see because it's it's it's
it's a it's a deconfliction technology
that doesn't have a central a central
force for example you don't need a bank
for two people to do business together
because they've got a DLT a larger
technology that allows them to do it
without that without both trusting the
bank bank that provides a single central
ledger that was the obvious case in the
IOT space for example we have test beds
in the manufacturing space and we'd like
the manufacturing devices to be able to
talk to something in the ending and know
and and know that that they are
entrusted then the DLT is an obvious way
to note that we were going to trust our
technology trustworthiness has become in
a major part of the way that we develop
the test beds today in fact we have a
paper out about a month ago on
trustworthiness and IOT systems and deal
tees are the best way to provide it but
i spent an enormous amount of time about
two years ago looking at specific TLT
technologies and said these are all
garbage they just don't understand the
real world for example I looked at one
not to be mentioned and it has a
transaction rate of seven transactions a
second I had just finished a project cut
IMG with Swift which does 700,000
transactions a second but I downloaded
it anyway just to see how it worked and
discovered that the download was 200 to
250 gigabytes well that's no way that's
going to work on a sensor in the CNC
machine or a device in a manufacturing
floor or a sensor of checking for lights
in that in an office and in this much to
my building or a ambulance etc etc there
had to be a better way but there wasn't
so I gave up I said this TLT stuff is
just not up to snuff yet I'm gonna use
it
through a friend I met Dominic Sheena
and then later David Hassan subbu I said
these guys have a solution that's better
these guys have a solution that's
something like a 30 megabyte and
transaction rate in the millions of
transactions a second they've seen this
they've seen the DLT promise and they
understand the real needs of real people
that's something I wanted to be involved
in but I found out that there was no
standard for them for what they were
doing for that for that TLT the IO to
tangle so that's why I'm G immediately
got involved in Tavella to develop a
standard in that space got it and so one
of the things that I'm very interested
in is this idea of a distributor letter
technology of blockchain etc being a
operating system for the Internet of
Things right allowing for true
automation there's plenty of people who
either disagree that that's possible or
to think that don't think that's gonna
happen but it just feels like it's not
possible to have true automation and
machine to machine transactions if the
asset of value right whether it's a
stock of on the currency or commodity if
that's not truly digital right if it's
still an electronic cue sip and then
obviously if it's physical paper or
something it just isn't compatible right
and I can't get over the fact that
people don't see that do you agree with
that or do you have some other vision of
the world and where we're going no I
absolutely agree with that no question
first of all you mentioned keys if I
should mention the OMG has a standard
called Figgy which is a better solution
a moronic or all-encompassing solution
to the problem specifying not only of
primary equities but derivatives to Bill
developed from those equities on
multiple markets should take a look fi
GI but those things are electronic
whether they're acusa fergie or anything
else today nobody you mean the hundred
years ago you used to see people walking
down Wall Street gang chiefs of paper
that doesn't happen anymore it all
happens electronically but it's
everything should happen electronically
there's no reason we can't trade
properties trade I says we trade money
today and that's gonna require a
trustworthy way to do so
our trustworthiness paper is worth
looking at it's better to understand
that trustworthiness becomes the
centerpiece of IOT systems and you've
got to deliver that in the way that you
say that you trust for us that means
it's VLT if you can build the DLT that
doesn't that doesn't have a single point
of failure doesn't have a huge download
constraint and is fast enough to handle
the transaction rates that we see in the
real world today for sure and part of it
I guess is you're not gonna go to a
world of hey the cars driving down the
street and pays the toll by driving over
a sensor tomorrow right that's kind of a
more complex it involves much more
investment in infrastructure not both in
the public and private sector and so you
can understand the complexities are
going to take time and significant
dollar investments but it sounds like
you see this not only in those larger
integrations of technology and sensors
and endpoints but also on a much much
smaller scale and in a shorter time
period as well oh absolutely absolutely
I mean so first III do pay tolls
electronically every day unfortunately
and I do go through a electronic
Tollbooth that I can hardly even see in
a box next to my mirror does pay the
toll and I got to fill the box every now
and then but it's all electronic and I
think that's the point we're trying to
make but making it smaller with us with
smaller investment is got to be critical
so for example we have a testbed in in
Germany in Holmberg and southwestern
Germany
that's reinventing the way factories
work all it does is it tracks people
parts work-in-progress and tools for
things everything inside the factory and
to see whether we can provide a safer
factory for the human beings that work
there and provide a more efficient
factory for the people that own the
factory and they answers obviously yes
but how exactly I give you some examples
we know where the people are we know
where the robot arms are we stop the
robots when the people get near so they
don't get hurt and that's a lot better
than the solution that's currently done
which is to put robots in cages so that
people don't accidentally walk in then
and get hurt by the robot you can do a
lot better than that if you know whether
or
you know where the people are but the
productivity message is even stronger
for example we know where the tools are
and we know what job you're supposed to
do we aware that where to send you to
pick up the tool there was a factory
this this testbed is managed by Bosch
like by the way they have a customer
that a factory from a company that I'm
not supposed to mention where the people
in the factory were spending 46 percent
of their time looking for the tool for
the next job 46 percent of the time
crazy
manufacturing people are never surprised
by a number but I was I was shocked in
that factory now the system which knows
where the tools are says your next job
is so-and-so
you have to do it in and so on so time
and the tool to do that job is 10 meters
behind you on the left side because a
knows where the tools are
imagine the productivity that makes a
difference that when the people in the
factory are spending 46 percent of their
time looking for the next tool imagine
it but that means I've got to trust the
system I've got a trust that it knows
what what jobs need to be done
I gotta trust the tool which knows where
it is and it's reporting its location
I've got to trust that it is one of the
tools that I'm supposed to be looking
out for all those things required to
some element of trust which might be
handled with a central party put his
handle for the DLP because I may not be
able to guess the special party and
maybe down or worse in MIDI hat yeah
it's so interesting right the the part
that I keep going back to here is the
best technologies in the world are in
companies are market expanding right so
if you think of uber as one example
where if you had looked at nuber early
on and said oh it's a black car okay
what market it could disrupt is you know
kind of limousines and black cars a
little bit bigger market probably the
extent of where most people thought was
Oh what if they could actually do
something as crazy as disrupt the taxi
business right and how big is that
market well what Hoover actually ended
up doing was not only disrupting
limousines and taxis but then it also
expanded the total addressable market to
include people who had cars right now
they just don't drive their cars when
they're drunk and things like that and
they expanded that market opportunity it
feels like the technology that you're
talking about around Internet of Things
and these protocols and the connectivity
if you look at it from a kind of an
obvious perspective there's some market
cap that exists but it feels like it is
a technology that can drastically expand
over time and there's probably things
that get created that we can't even
imagine today no more be very hard to
imagine what what could potentially out
come out from this yeah well I'm gonna
try to imagine for you what I can first
of all I should mention the uber uber
didn't just trend and change the car the
car business
uber changed the dispatch business it
did away with dispatch business taxes
are not dispatched by human beings
anymore that's a pretty important change
if you're in the dispatch business
before I think we're gonna see those
kinds of changes from ayah from IOT to
some what Mike and I can see now for
example smart devices devices that are
attached to the factory than created
them forever devices that automatically
tell them a manufacturer unfailing you
need to send a maneuver a new one today
because some part is who replaced I I
think we're gonna see a day when a toy
in my house has a failing part I don't
even know about it but I have a
replacement part in the mail one day
without asking for it because it knows
and it's connected to the Internet and
the internet connects all this all these
things and so if people don't realize
how important that is so I think smart
devices are major a major source of IOT
new product opportunities new business
models but we're gonna see others
because that's one of the things we're
trying to learn with our testbed program
what are the new in the new of business
models can we discover what those
business models are and how do we
address those business models absolutely
it's going to expand the market but
nobody really knows how exactly all I
know is I can do a better business if I
understand what my business better
understand that data that's collecting
and understanding what to do with that
data
I have several friends that are running
companies that that collect data around
cars internet connected vehicles they're
called not necessarily self-driving
vehicles just vehicles that understand
their surroundings
my son for example is an expert in this
area internet connected vehicles
Alexander soli is written quite
extensively on the subject and it's
amazing but it requires that the vehicle
knows where it is knows what it is and
that you have trust in the data that it
is reporting that's going to require a
DLT because there's no way that every
car on the planet is going to talk to a
central authority ever there's no
central authority that can deal with
that much that much emirate first sir
what what do you think is the biggest
obstacle or a potential reason why this
could all fail yeah you know that's a
good question I just answered that for
summer for someone else in the press
earlier today I'm supposed to answer the
security everybody says its security and
its net ain't security I mean obviously
I want my systems to be secure I wanted
to be private and I want to be able to
trust the results that I get from
sensors and sensor devices that are
plugged into my devices but that's not
the problem today we've discovered in
our testbed program the biggest problem
by far is finding the expertise to build
these systems and that is one of the
things that we're collecting by building
the actual systems is collecting
expertise and we're proud of that yeah
it's really really interesting to start
thinking about what what's what's
possible here you're also one of the
other things you're doing is you're on
the supervisory board as a member for
FRA Oda and they are they're sponsoring
the automation series that we're doing
maybe talk a little bit as to what the
the attraction was there and what you're
doing at in the role as a supervisory
board member sure I'm happy to as I
mentioned that about a year or two ago I
was introduced to tomshino we had lunch
in Frankfurt and and we've had a deep
friendship ever since I've also met that
well I met on skype David's unstable and
I realized these two not only had a
technology that could change the world
but a technology that was being
intelligently handled and tells of them
and it related problems out in front
where people could see them and problems
being solved by a community that
understands the technology understands
why to make the technology better when
Dom asked me to join the stitch and
throughout the supervisory board I
number four he said he basically was
looking for gray hair looking for
somebody with some experience running
startup companies that can help them put
together a useful company that would
build that system build it intelligently
and they're doing that today I've been
to some some now this past summer that's
the summer summit of the IDA Foundation
and it's a team that's incredibly
impressive and understands the
technology that they're building and why
they're building it as much as they're
as they understand the individual jobs
for sure and then in terms of the
Supervisory Board maybe talk a little
bit about exactly exactly what that is
in kind of why you know what white joint
sure I don't want to get into the
details of chairman corporate structure
but I heard a foundation is in fact a
German foundation and therefore has two
boards like all companies in Germany and
I'm a member of the upper board that
makes sure that the lower board actually
understands what what they're doing and
has members on on that lower board that
that can manage the company on day to
day basis so I'm not involved in the
day-to-day management of the company I'm
brought in sort of as an advisor to make
sure that we have a strong board and a
strong team to deliver and the tango
intelligent form yeah and so what is
your thoughts on creating a standardized
protocol around Internet of Things and
how that is in line with or competes
with a standard currency or token right
so what I mean by that is that there's
the flow of information and then there
is something that can be used of value
as well are those two things that
compete with each other or did they can
be complementary maybe you think they
can be the same thing like how like how
do you think about that trade-off yeah
so some of the protocols already exists
it's not just protocols or standards
look like either protocols or languages
or or api's programming interfaces in
this case is the set of programming
interfaces some protocols and
and the data model of the tango itself
there's not in those are not in
contradiction you can hear those those
specific protocols 2d LTS on top of
standard protocols like korva DVS and
cuties and key Z Z and so forth so I'm
not worried at the competitive I am
worried that the designed intelligently
so they are likely to be adopted by
vendors and users alike so there's a
real reason to expect those standards to
come out on top of the standards that we
already have what's the thing that
you're most excited about in this
standard in the standards kind of corner
of the world is there is there some area
that hasn't been conquered yet or
standard hasn't been issued that you're
saying hey that this is a place that I
think so we should go look at oh there
are lots of places where standards need
to be developed and haven't been
developed yet the IOT space digital
twins that and the entire maturity of
digital transformation needs to be
addressed and the low-level standards
for DLT is obviously important and
that's why we're working on them or why
we're working with it at a foundation
there are lots of areas in verticals and
in on the platform where standards would
make that the world an easier place to
work with so I'm excited about all of
them I'm not gonna get I'm not gonna let
you get any of my chairs mad at me all
right before before I finish up I always
do some more rapid-fire questions other
than Nyota is there a company in the
blockchain or crypto space that that
you're excited about oh good question
except um I'm not gonna mention any
names I just talked to a friend who's
got a blockchain start off in in New
York that specializes in digitizing any
any any resource at all it could be
anything that says you want to trade I
think that's the the right sort of thing
you should do with whatever blockchain
happens to win maybe one more than one
blockchain technology I don't care if
it's Bitcoin in theory and I do or
whatever
what is the one regulation that you
would change in technology if you could
wave a magic wand and change it okay
there's very little regulation and
technology no I
some of the more amusing regulations
that have been suggested went by the
wayside for example when when when I
knew the digital commissioner of the
European Community proposed to standard
a regulation standard that said that you
would not be able to solve you would not
be able to ship any IOT device in the
European Union unless it passed some
security test that he had in mind
it all sounds perfectly nice except
there were no security tests and there's
an obvious solution which is don't call
your product an IOT product anymore that
regulation who was killed before was
stillborn it was killed before it
started and I think that most
regulations and technology looked like
that that's there they come from people
not really truly understanding of
technology or how the technology affects
society yeah what's the most important
book you'd ever read you know there are
a lot of important books and I know I'm
supposed to say the Bible but I love to
say Scott works by been rich it really
teaches you to think outside the box it
talks about the creation of the f-117 a
fighter the sr-71 reconnaissance
aircraft and all sorts of lessons about
how to build the aircraft differently
how to think about engineering in large
engineering projects out of subtle
things and how to solve an unsolvable
problems in ways that are just not
that's not the way you'd think of I just
bought a copy from a friend of mine and
I buy copies for friends all the time
just so they can understand thinking
outside the box
aliens believer or non-believer let me
just say with this many stars in this
many galaxies and in the universe
there's no chance zero chance that none
of the other ones on the other planets
around the star somewhere it didn't
create some form of life unfortunately
we have the limitation of the speed of
light so I'm not sure we're ever going
to meet any aliens but are there are
there other forms of life absolutely I
tend to agree with you and think that
that is the most logical and safest
argument as to why aliens are very very
very likely to exist so
[Music]
you you have a agree or here in me I end
each podcast letting somebody ask me a
question what one question do you have
for me I love asking this question I ask
it all the time have you shorted Bitcoin
yet are you not a Bitcoin believer not
at ten thousand dollars I'm not a big
believer No
one of the arguments about Bitcoin is
there's nothing behind it but there's
nothing but on the US dollar either so
that shouldn't matter well excuse me but
what's the Federal Reserve what's your
game banker credit what is this a great
lady of Threadneedle Street there are
actually banks behind fiat currencies
and there's nothing behind Bitcoin so
there's no reason for the price to be so
incredibly high I'm not saying that this
should be it should be valueless that's
a different argument but the price
should be incredibly high I don't think
it's gonna hold well what is the price
that you would go from non-believer to
it's interesting oh that's a hard
question but certainly nowhere near
where it is today I'm thinking more like
10 to 20 dollars I love it I love it
yeah look III think that what you're
talking about is like the infrastructure
around the fiat currency it's not just
infrastructure those banks actually
defend their currencies the US Federal
Reserve defends the dollar nobody
defends Bitcoin and I think we're seeing
an incredibly high price for Bitcoin
simply because the demand is is quite
large and then the supply is quite small
which the economists tell us causes high
prices to go up
but when demand Falls I don't think
supply is going to change but when
demand Falls they might see a tremendous
change in value so I will agree with you
that Federal Reserve other central banks
are prone to defend their currency
that's absolutely a factual statement
what is your reaction if I made the
argument that the miners in cohort with
the difficulty adjustment built into the
Bitcoin blockchain algorithm defended
the currency as well they don't they
don't fund the currency they they defend
they defend they defended the the
available supply of currency absolutely
but that's it whereas the Federal
Reserve has I think it's four different
controls over over monetary control that
in case of Bitcoin you have only the
difficulty and it makes a difference to
have fiscal control and monetary control
to say that it doesn't make a difference
is it's just missing the fact of how
didhow fiat currency works yeah and I
get the the argument that people would
have rankings there there's a lot of
people and I'm not even playing there's
a lot of people who I think would agree
with you on that
around fiat currencies monetary control
that the role of central bank's etc I
guess the argument or one of the
arguments that folks in the
cryptocurrency community would have is
that if you are taking an action to
defend your currency that ultimately
manipulates it and over a long period of
time hurts it are you actually defending
it or are you simply trading short-term
benefit for long-term loss right so an
example would be as you print more of
the currency to defend it you're really
just debasing it at a faster rate and
therefore you lose purchasing power over
time right I guess it's the Frank that
some would use right there in other
words the argument you're making is
fiscal versus monetary control which
every every central bank has to deal
with all the time that simply doesn't
exist in in the cryptocurrency world I'm
not saying all cryptocurrency is bad I'm
a deep believer for example in an iota
currency it war where it's just today is
I think as a reasonable price although
it's hard to say what's reasonable when
it's just about demand the supply but
comparing it and in any sense the fiat
currency I think is a mistake I got it
look III always appreciate people who
have an understanding of monetary policy
fiat currencies and and even though we
disagree on is Bitcoin valuable or not
you have a very logical argument right
it's the people the people who are
frustrating right to talk to are the
people who just say
you know it's stupid it's a bubble if
that type of stuff right so I actually
appreciate when people have a very
well-defined position and reasoning as
to why they believe what they believe
which I think that your position is uh
is fair you know looking like a good
Bitcoin investor okay it's a there's a
balance right it is
I think contrary to popular belief I am
actually not at all emotional about
Bitcoin in terms of like a religious
zealot type emotion it to me is just
much more a belief in the fact that
people like you said right it's a supply
and demand type equation and I have a
thesis on why demand will continue to
increase over a long period of time
right and that's really where my belief
and comfort right and trust in storing
wealth there comes from and it literally
is just that people are going to
actually trust and transparent algorithm
and software with their wealth and and
the monetary policy decisions rather
than trust humans yeah I understand the
argument I have respect for that
argument as well I don't entirely agree
I think there are other places to store
money and that have the same problem by
the way gold is the obvious case I mean
it has fluctuated in my lifetime between
$100 an ounce a troy ounce and a couple
thousand dollars a troy ounce because
there's nothing backing it either and
the intrinsic value of gold is pretty
low right and it's just it's a good
thing it's the best conductor but other
than that it's not very interesting
diamonds molybdenum there are a lot of
cases where where metals and minerals
are precious at much higher than their
intrinsic values so I understand the
argument it's a reasonable argument it's
simply not the one that I'm following
today I I hear you all right listen
this is super fun I really appreciate
you taking the time to come talk for
about 45 minutes or so I think that
people will get a ton out
this and you've had a long storied
career and push the pace on on standards
across a whole bunch of industries so I
really appreciate how you taking time to
kind of give us an insight into your
world and they'll have to do it again in
the future as as you continue to
establish these these standards in
various industries over over the years
ago looking forward to it thanks for
taking the time hey everyone pop here if
you like this episode of off the chain
and want to help us take crypto to the
top of the Apple Spotify and other
podcast charts please do us a favor and
rate review and subscribe to review
simply go to the off-the-chain home page
scroll down until you see the five blank
stars taking 15 seconds to fill those
stars in and leave a quick review goes a
long way in helping us take the entire
crypto ecosystem to the top of the
charts I appreciate you listening and
see you next time on off the chain